- [Instructor] Our
squirrel friend here likes
to collect acorns, because, really,
that's how he is able to live.
And let's say everyday, he
collects exactly three acorns.
And so what I'm curious
about is how many acorns
will he have after doing
this for five days?
So one way to think about
it is every day he is able
to collect a group of three acorns.
So you could view this
as maybe what he's able
to collect in day one.
And then in day two, he's
able to collect a second group
of three acorns.
In day three, he's able
to collect another group
of three acorns.
And every day it's a
equal number of acorns
that he's collecting.
On the fourth day, another three.
On the fifth day, another three.
And so if you were curious
how many total acorns
he's collected, well, you
could just count them up,
or you could think about,
well, he's got five
groups of three acorns.
Five equal groups of three acorns.
So you could say five groups
of three acorns, three acorns.
And so the total amount would be five,
we could view this as five threes.
Now, five threes, you could view this
as five threes added together.
Three plus three, plus three,
plus three, plus three.
And if you wanted to calculate this,
you could skip count by three.
So this would be three, six, nine, 12, 15,
because we add three, we get to six,
we add another three, we get to nine,
we add another three, we get to 12,
we add another three, we get to 15.
And so this would be a way of recognizing
that you have 15 acorns,
but we're starting to touch
on one of the most fundamental
ideas in all of mathematics.
In fact, we actually are applying it,
we just haven't used the world,
and that's, we are multiplying.
We are using multiplication.
All multiplication is
is this notion of multiple
equal groups of something.
So, here, one way to
express what we just did,
is we just, when we said five threes,
that's the same thing as five,
and I'm going to introduce
a new symbol to you,
five times three.
So all of these things are equivalent.
You're already used to seeing equal groups
and multiple equal groups,
and you're used to adding
something multiple times,
and you're used to skip counting,
and all of that is, in
some way shape or form,
you have been doing multiplication.
So when someone says five times three,
you could view that is
five groups of three,
or you could view that as five threes,
or you could view that
as three plus three,
plus three, plus three,
or you could view that as 15.
I'll leave ya there.
There's a lot of practice on Khan Academy
to work through this
and make sure you get the underlying idea.
But as you'll see, this is
perhaps one of the most useful
concepts that you might
learn in your entire lives.